- Today is the day I become a vampire.
This is Anthony.
He's a vampire.
I'm pescatarian.
We went on a date and
he just wooed me so much
that he has convinced
me to become a vampire
and get fangs, just like him.
- We're going to see Father Sebastiaan
and get your teeth
molded, create the tooth,
and then sculpt it.
- So there's no chance of me getting hurt
by doing the fangs.
- No, no, no.
The process is kind of
like going to the dentist.
- [Solarm] Can I see
your fangs one more time?
- Yeah, of course.
- My mom always said don't
make big changes for a man,
and here I am.
- Hi, we're Radiant Tattoo, Inc.
My name is Father
Sebastiaan, Master Fangsmith
and Empressario of the
Endless Night Vampire Ball.
I make custom made fangs
for the vampire community.
To enter the vampire community,
it is pretty predominant
that you go to a fangsmith as
your first right of passage
to become a vampire.
Today, I'm going to
make Solarm some fangs.
The first step is the oath,
where she learns how to
take care of the fangs.
So I need you to raise
your hands in the air,
like Ozzy Osborne, and repeat after me,
by the power of Sebastiaan.
- By the power of Sebastiaan.
- I will not eat or
sleep with my fangs on.
- I will have amazing
sex with my fangs on.
- And I can smoke and drink with my fangs.
- And I will not look in the mirror
until I have been given permission.
- Woo.
- Anthony has already gotten his fangs,
so he's here for moral
support and musical support.
Yes.
- [Solarm] These are my fangs.
These are going to be in my mouth.
- [Sebastiaan] Lips up, under your lips.
(guitar plays softly)
- We're going to take the fangs off now.
- I was afraid my teeth
were gonna come off.
Oh my goodness.
- We've got a good mold.
(drill whirs)
We're gonna give you a secret name
that will only be known within
the vampire inner circle.
I got this book of ancient deities.
Between your hands is the
name of every known human god
and one of these names will be yours.
Just summon the name, suck the name out,
cause now you suck like a vampire.
Put your finger in the book
when you feel the urge.
- What is that?
Ixion.
He was the king, ow.
It hurts.
He was the king of the Lapiths of Thessaly
and he was married to Dia.
I just want it to sound cool.
- You can make it feminine by Ixiona.
- Oh, I like that.
I'm going to be Ixiona.
- So we give you a gift of Ankh.
The legacy in the saber tooth clan,
now you're a saber tooth.
- Oh my god, this is like Anastasia.
(heavenly music plays)
Okay, now I get to actually to see myself.
I sound crazy guys.
- Okay, one, two, three.
(Solarm laughs)
- Oh my god.
I'm a vampire.
Anthony come look at these.
- Oh, wow.
- Twins.
- Twinsies.
- You notice anything different about me?
- Are your boobs bigger?
- What's on your teeth?
- Oh, you have fangs.
- You have a lisp.
You have a vampire lisp.
- I just feel like you
could kill me right now.
- I could kill you right now.
- But, don't.
- Why are we in this hallway?
What's going on?
Why'd you lure me in here?
- Whoa.
They're sharp.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, like, how you supposed to
give head like that?
- You know what though, I
think it looks really dope.
- Do you think you'd get
vampire fangs like this?
- I don't know, actually.
I've never tried fangs, so
don't knock it til you try it.
- Got some fang shui on your face.
- Fang shui.
They're fangtastic.
- Yeah, are you pretty fangful for them?
- I'm very fangful for
them, thank you for asking.
My vampire name is Ixiona.
- What does that mean?
- It's a greek person.